Hey Beth!
Hello! How's it going?
Great! Now that we're here.
How are you?
Oh, so good. So happy to be here with you.
I thought that we would talk today about image analysis as a career.
How do you get into it as a career?
So this is sort of a question we get from folks.
You know, hey, I've done a bunch of, you know, I've done a bunch of
image analysis in grad school or in my postdoc or what
this is a thing i'm actually really interested in
And I think I want to be an image analyst.
But I don't know how to make this transition from having
done image analysis to being an image analyst.
What do I do?
Yeah, that's that's so hard because it's a career that a lot of us fall into by accident
I'd love to hear what I should have done to do it on purpose.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, so here and some adorable little AI-generated woodland creatures
are going to help give us some answers to the question of like, so you want to be an image
analyst? What do you do? So informational interviews were the starting point, that idea that I had here,
just reach out to current image analysts, people who are doing the thing that you want to do,
ask them about what do they actually do on a day-to-day basis. This might help you understand
like, yeah, this is actually the path I want to follow or it's like, oh, that's what that looks
like. Maybe I don't really want to be an image analyst. Yeah, the amount of data cleaning,
then like stuff that comes into it that you don't think is much about with your own data,
because you know your own data. Yes, yeah. Yeah, so you may learn things. You're like, oh, actually,
the day-to-day practicality of this job is not something that I really think I'm going to enjoy.
So maybe I'll explore other things or you may see like, yeah, there's some technical skills there.
Like, I've certainly built up category A of technical skills, but now that I hear what this
person does, I see like, oh, yes, I'm missing that set of skills. So you have a, you know, a target
of what to work on. You know, and again, just hearing what is their career path? How did they
get to where they want to be? Can give you some ideas about how do you get there as well? Even if
lots of the time it's, well, I kind of stumbled into it. Hearing enough people stumbling may give
you some ideas. If enough people stumble in the same direction, a path may start to be formed.
Yeah. Likewise, you'd, informational interviews, you can reach out to like hiring managers,
recruiters, you know, senior scientists who have image analysts on their team.
I would say, first of all, like, do this not connected to a specific job position,
especially if you're interested in applying for that specific job. Oftentimes,
you know, I can say for people who are, you know, have applied to a job that we are hiring,
we are not allowed to tell them anything specific because they have applied to that job. We cannot
tell them like, this is the skill you're missing. This is what we were looking for. Like, once you've
applied, our tongues are bound. Yeah. And it's so frustrating because we would love to be able
to be more candid, but legally we cannot. Yes. Yeah. So, but if somebody reaches out to us
outside of a specific job to say, you know, hey, this is where I'm at. Like, what are you looking
for? Even, and even less, actually, I sort of take back that very first sentence, don't tell us about
yourself. Ask us about what we're looking for because, you know, it's a hard line to balance,
but particularly if you go in talking about yourself in an informational interview, it sounds
like you're asking for a job. And so immediately, you know, if that's the case, my answer is usually
like, actually, we're not hiring right now. Sorry. And that's kind of end of conversation. But if it's
showing a really genuine interest in, I'm really excited about what your team does. And I want to
know more about how one would get there. Like, what are you looking for? What do people that you have
hired? What are they great at? What skills might any person want to develop to get there? That's
how you'll have the most success navigating that kind of conversation. Yeah.
Then, in terms of like accelerating your own learning, like, hopefully you have figured out
where your strengths and not strengths are. And so,
growth areas. Growth areas. Yeah. And so once you find a growth area, grow it, right? Bootcamps are
a great way to do that. I mean, there's lots of other ways to get skills. But sometimes,
if you have a day job, that takes, you know, there's only so much that you can necessarily
branch out in within your day to day, right? You have other work that you must do. And if that is
not all do image analysis, right? Like, well, how do I build those skills? And so, lots of bootcamps
out there. You know, we have one a few times a year. So, you can certainly look at our lab
website for more on that. But we are not the only team that does bootcamps. And yeah.
I'm seeing more and more. And it's great. And I think just the, however it's structured, just
like having a schedule to learn something. Like, it's so easy to be like, oh, gosh, I wish I had
time to learn, you know, X. And then you're like, I will. But if you don't schedule it, at least
for me, I know it's never gonna, like, I'm never gonna get around to that long list of things I
wish I had time to learn. Like, scheduling it, whatever that looks like for you. And again,
there's more and more bootcamps I'm seeing out there, which is great. Like, really can be the
difference between actually getting over that, that busyness barrier or not. Absolutely.
Yeah. The forum, image.sc, this comes up in, again, lots of our podcast episodes, but it's a great
place to hang out online for many reasons. You can hear about training opportunities,
like bootcamps, and such are announced there. Likewise, like developments in the field,
people will announce like, Hey, here's a brand new software, or here's, you know, a new tool,
or a new workflow, or hey, here's a conversation that experts in the field are having, and we're
wrestling with this right now. So you have the opportunity to see what is going on in the field.
How can I learn, you know, what is out there for me to be able to learn more?
This is the thing that experts are really wrestling with. So that's a place I want to dive in. So I
can be state of the field and have, you know, really state of the field things to say when I do
have an interview for an image analysis position. You can ask questions. It's a place where, you
know, not only can you ask questions about a specific image analysis task that you're trying
to perform. And we have a great podcast episode about how do you ask good questions in terms of
getting help about your specific biology. But you can network there to meet other people in the field.
And I definitely know I am way like the few times that we've had where somebody applies to a job with
us. And I'm like, they include their forum handle, and I can go and look and see that they've been
helpful on the forum. Like that that raises them up so much in my like, Oh, look, like, this person
already knows how to do what we do. Yeah. Yeah. And even, you know, already knows and cares, like
clearly, they want, you know, they want to engage, they want to be an image analyst. It's not just,
Oh, this is a job. I need a job. Oh, yeah, they have to be quality posts. It can't just be like a
whole bunch of like, bump me to like, but if you see that they're going in and helping people, like,
that for me is a huge like, yes, I have so much Tristan, this person's knowledge, but also this
person being a good team player. Yeah. Yeah. And yeah. And then finally, professional networks and
conferences. So another way of interacting with other bio image analysts, go to conferences that
are heavy on bio imaging. Even if you're at a conference that is not necessarily, you know,
if you go to ASCB, which is a giant just sort of cell biology conference, go to the talks
that are about imaging, meet other people, you know, introduce yourself, say, Hey,
awesome talk. I want to learn more about your image analysis pipeline that you showed, you know,
can I can I hear more about that? Yeah, poster sessions, like if somebody's got images and
then a graph next to it on their poster, how did you get from there to there? Yeah, absolutely.
And, you know, and there's a bunch of professional societies as well, all around the world,
that are focused around bio image analysis and microscopy. And we have another podcast episode,
we'll drop it in the show notes that talking about these conferences and societies. So I'm not
going to say it, but I do have a whole list of recommendations there. But that is, you know,
another way to, again, hear about what's going on the field, meet other people that are doing the
same thing, a great way to meet, to make connections, meet people, learn things and show that you're
really interested in this area. Yeah, I think that's the one, the one sort of extra thing that I
will say on here, and you kind of alluded to it already is just like, with all of these things,
you'll need to understand that like, people are busy, like, generally speaking, this is a super
kind and helpful community. And so many people I know, including me, like, have gotten into this
community based on like, they talked to somebody, they got a leg up, and like, you know, people are
very willing to help you, but somebody might not be able to help you right now. And if you come in
with an attitude of like, you need to help me, a, like, you know, you're not going to be predisposed
person to it, but also like, this is a career that's really about working well with others,
like, demonstrate when you go to ask people for help that you can work well with others and a,
they're more like that help you, but be also like, you will demonstrate that you're a great fit for
this community. One of the great things about this group is everybody is so helpful, and people
will almost certainly want to help you, but make it make it easy for them to do it. And if someone's
like, you know, I'm sorry, I'm really busy right now, you know, have a couple other names on your
list, you can reach out to, but if you do that, I guarantee like, so many kind people in this community
will want to help. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. And I think just triggered another thought of, you know,
if you are reaching out to somebody, reach out with bounded specifics, you know, hey,
can I have 15 minutes of your time? I'd like to ask you question x, y and z, period. And then
stick to that, right? Like, great, here's a Zoom meeting. How, you know, here's my agenda, and
here's our 15 minutes. And because, you know, you and I both wish we had hours to give every
single person who ever reached out to us. And sometimes there are times when we don't even
have those 15 minutes. But there's other times when we absolutely do. But by making a clear,
concrete, respectful ask, it's much easier to get somebody to agree to it than the like, you know.
Yeah. And I will add one more thing there, which is authentic. In the age of generative AI,
nothing makes me less excited to give more of my time than to somebody who clearly like,
just asked a chatbot what they should ask me and doesn't seem like they have genuine excitement
that is their own. It seems like their excitement is borrowed from a chatbot.
Which is not to say you can't use them again. They're very useful, especially if English is not
your first language and things like that. But make sure that you're not, that you sound like you.
That you don't sound like the current flavor of large language model. Because people who get
lots of these requests will notice that yours sounds exactly like everybody else's and will assume
that you're not actually as excited as you say you are. Yeah, absolutely. Great point.
Well, thank you. This is going to help so many people. I'm so excited that you did this.
I hope so. I really hope so. Because, you know, image analysts are great and this is an awesome
career and I want to help more people get here. Yeah, absolutely. We need more great colleagues
come hang out with us. Yeah. All right. Bye, hon.